another and this isn't just now it's  absolutely historically 8 000 years ago  guess how many women reproduced for  every one man  guess how so so for every girl that  reproduced  like for every one guy that reproduced  guess how many girls reproduced for him  i don't even want to know  i don't even know  tender one okay what do you think i'll  probably like eight eight  can i say ten 10 yeah same i'm thinking  a little bit higher because what do you  want to take into account like  definitely  taking two because i do know  genghis khan like a lot of people that  are living oh yeah  i'm going to take i'm going to take a  shot in the dark and go 1 in 25.  you're closest  17 women reproduced for every one man 8  000 years ago yeah